(city sounds, subway train squeal)
- [Narrator] One spring afternoon in 2015,
I decided to visit the world in a day.
New York opens itself up to
those willing to explore it,
and so the view from
elsewhere can be glimpsed
and enjoyed by wandering the city streets.
I want to witness all
across the city how people
take their home country
with them to New York
and adapt easily or uneasily
to this challenging metropolis.
I want to see how people long
for home, I want to observe
how they declare "this is my home."
For as long as I can
remember, I've been a walker,
one who makes sense of the
world by strolling through it.
Many immigrants from
countries where the walker
has not been displaced by
the automobile lay claim
to the city by grasping it
underfoot, they warm up to it
at walking pace, so I walk
to connect with the city,
but also to connect with other
immigrants who pursue home.
Step by step, encounter by encounter,
ambition by ambition, the way I do.
(light electric guitar)
(upbeat jazzy music)